[Music]  ladies and gentlemen my name is  Professor Philip Goodman my job is to  explain the unexplainable untangle the  truth from the fiction you don't have to  have your life ruled by superstitious  fear everything you spent a lifetime  trying to debunk the supernatural it's  all three kisses I couldn't explain you  an investigate if he did things are not  always [ __ ]  tell me about your incident you don't  believe here hello I don't people  looking at me and thinking I'm mad  because I know what I saw  do you believe in evil professor  I didn't until that night Maria these  are signs I know you're still there  the spirit I understand how easy it is  to get confused and then in force get  into your head like everything is  exactly as it seems you don't know  everything but I like the brain sees  what it wants to see  [Music]  [Music]